hello everyone and welcome to another
game from grande chest towards your next
move tournament in Leuven it's a rapid
tournament the players are battling it
out for a prize fund of one hundred and
fifty thousand dollars first place being
I believe some forty thousand dollars
maybe a bit less so definitely a lot of
money and it's very interesting to win
you know every leg of the Grantchester
so you can be the winner of the grand
chest were in total here we have a game
between Viswanathan Anand and Fabiano
Caruana so the world chess championship
challenger faces the world former world
champion but also the reigning champion
in in rapid chess as you know in 2017
Anand won the world rapid chess
championship so a very interesting
matchup and since if you've seen in my
previous video Korona didn't have the
best start in day one only half a point
out of three games so in this game -
Anand z4 he replies not with E 5 so he
doesn't go for his spatter of defense
rather he goes for the Sicilian so we're
gonna check it out but before that I did
prepare another photo challenge hope it
will be you know sufficiently difficult
not too difficult so best of luck to
everyone who is this very nice gentleman
so there you have it
for those of you who may not know this I
will give you only a slight hint he did
win second place in the 1959 candidates
tournament of course you all know who
won first place I'm not even gonna say
it so there you have it best of luck to
everyone and I don't have a photo of
this encounter but I did have I do have
a print screen of from the live feed if
you want you can check out the live
coverage it's you know been held every
day and enjoy some live commentary by
yasser sara vaughn and johann Kokoschka
so that being said let's check out this
game I really enjoyed this game sorry
about that
it's really like a school example of how
of how to win games
noting that there will be a winner in
this game but you know you'll see what I
mean
so on and opened with e4 c5 like we said
the Sicilian defense Knight to f3 d6 d4
C captures Knight captures and
a six the Khan variation of the Sicilian
Bishop to d3 Bishop to c5 Knight to b3
attacking the Bishop on c5 Bishop is
tucked in safely to a7 Queen to e2
Knight to c6 simply developing Bishop to
e3 night g7 Knight 1 to D to castles
castles and knights the e5 now Bishop
captures an a7 rook captures an a7 and
f4 so all in all attacking the knight on
e5 and this awkward position of the rook
on a7 will be used by Anand later on to
remain over his queen to wherever the
Queen needs to go knife captor son d3 CP
after son b 3 and a 5 now so as you can
see unlike unlike in the usual Sicilian
it's actually white here who has a very
strong center so Queen to have to now
Rima nuvaring the queen by attacking the
rook on a 7 rook to a6 and now Knight
the d4 d6 rook 8 2 c1 Bishop to d7 and
not nice to see for attacking that d6
pawn sorry about that
b5 we have nice - III and Queen to b6
now again attacking the knight on d4
Knight to f3 rook 8 to 8 nice to see -
and now Queen captures on f2 accepting
the trade of Queens
King captures and now rook F to c8 we
have night C 2 D for now offering a
trade of rooks be for King to e3
now you can see that if you know both
rooks get exchanged and even the pieces
get exchanged then you can see that
annette has a much more active King his
King is already on a3 and caranas King
is all the way on g8 f 6 we have knight
back to e to e 5 now and rook captures
on CA
rook captures and rook to see one Bishop
to e6
attacking the a to pawn rook captures
with Czech Knight captures and b3 and
here we have a nice to be six if you
look at this position the the material
is equal both layers have to point I'll
answer the one difference that is
very noticeable Anand has two nights and
he's playing against a Coronas Bishop
and the night so a bishop will usually
be a better than a knight but it all
depends on the phone structure in the
endgame and here you can see that all of
Alan's pawns are on dark squares which
makes his Bishop a good Bishop but still
it's not the kind of position where this
Bishop will be better than a knight
so a bishop the g4 here would you know
he can always exchange it for either of
these Knights it would be it would be a
very nice move for for black for example
but after be three nights to be 6 by
Caruana we have d4 he captures on f4
with Czech Knight captures attacking the
bishop Bishop to d7 and d5 now we have
f5 attacking the e4 pawn Knight to d4
and now F captures on e4 King captures
on e4 and now King to f7 we have Knight
to c6 and here King to f6 is played if
you play something like a 4 with the
idea that you don't want to give up the
a5 pawn then still Knight will capture
it you will only give up the pawn in in
a different way
so after this knife the c6 King to f6
was played here we have Knight captures
on a5 Bishop to f5 check and here you
see the problem but to really understand
this problem we have to go all the way
back here
so here King to f6 was played with the
idea of after white captures on a5
Bishop to f5 is the idea then Bishop to
b1 and going after the a to pawn and
caranas idea is King to f6 so the King
can support it the bishop the bishop
bishops idea are coming to f5 but this
is actually the losing move for black
but it's so hard to find out why this is
the losing move that then when you see
why this is losing move then you will
see that g6 is in fact the correct way
to go also the idea is the same you
prepare Bishop to f5 but after King to
f6 undid capture the pawn on a5 we have
a bunch of to f5 check and now pink the
d4 getting out of check Bishop the b1
attacking the a to pawn and
this is where on earth could have who
won the game immediately but he played
nice to eat too and this is the problem
why King to f6 was the blunder because
Knight to h5 is actually the winning
move I told you the winning move I don't
want you to pause the video and figure
out why but it's so hard to figure out
why this is the winning move I will tell
you the first move and then you try to
figure out why it's winning so feel free
to pause the video here and you know
this is really difficult so you know
don't if you can spare time you know do
try and figure it out if you can't then
I just enjoy the show I like I did you
know I really enjoyed the show but yeah
I will give it a couple of seconds for
you to decide so for those of you who
found why night to h5 is the winning
move you are you know there's like III
have no words you are such an amazing
player and for those of you who in this
case like me just want to enjoy the show
nice to H won the five is winning
because okay the king is in check the g7
pawn is under attack and you have to
protect the g7 point you can either
protect it with 96 or night king king g6
or king of seven it doesn't matter what
you play for example King to have seven
now he play Knight to g3 and why night
to g3 is such a strong move you see only
after you capture the pawn Bishop
captures and now comes Knight to e4
you're attacking the d6 pawn you can you
can't allow whites to capture this if
white captures on d6 then king can come
to c5 the b4 point is going and then
it's a completely winning position so
you do have to defend the d6 point you
can either defend it with King to e7 or
ninth to see it it doesn't matter or
whatever you play you have to defend it
and then comes nice to d2 and this is
the whole point of this Knight to h5
check the bishop is not trapped
the bishop can't retreat and the bishop
is completely out of the game and if
white wants white can either simply cap
go here capture the bishop and then
continue playing the game
but either way black is lost here of
course such a such a maneuver would be
impossible to find in a rapid game but
it's one of the reasons I I decided to
show this game so a very nice variation
and you know a special congratulations
to everyone who found the idea behind 90
to h5 but ok Knight to e2 by Anand Anand
goes for a different line we have Bishop
captures and now Knight to the c1 he
defends the b3 pawn this way so the
knife from a5 can now move Bishop to B 1
as the bishop was attack tomato Knight
to c6 and now a h5 knife capture some
before so grabbing a pawn here
g5 and now Knight to e2 we have Knight
to d7 Knight to c3 now Bishop back to f5
and now Knight to c6 g4 before his
coming now Anand starts pushing his past
be pawn we have h4 Knight comes to b5
attacking the d6 pawn and there's a good
way to defend the pawn as the the night
and pawn are creating a wall against the
black king so nice to e5 we have Knight
captures pawn captures with check and
King to c5 now the King will support the
pushing of the past beep on as well as
the past deep on Bishop to d3 we have
nice to see 3 he doesn't fall out Bishop
captures as he wants the knight to be
able to to stop some of the pawns on the
King side g3 H capture son g3 g3 is a
very nice move because it fixes the Jie
du Pont on the light squares of the
bishop will be able to attack it later
on we have pawn captures pawn captures
and now d6 Bishop to f1 attacking the g2
pawn and now King to c6 Anand allows
Bishop captures and g2 because now the
d6 pawn is completely winning Bishop
captures on g2 we have King to c7 and
now Bishop to h3 preventing this push
and you could push this and you would
win a bishop but then you have a problem
with the Jeep on so first Knight to e4
check King moves and now Knight captures
and g3
getting rid of the past Jeep on King
moves 90 to check King moves and night
the g1 we have Bishop to g4 and here b5
was played and it was in this position
that Fabiano Caruana resigned in the
game there is nothing to do here for
black after you attack the knight white
will simply ignore you and after you
capture it the Queen comes into the game
and it's all over black has no counter
counter play whatsoever
so after b5 Quran or resign the game and
a very nice victory for the reigning
world rapid champion which monitor mound
will definitely have to wait and see how
he does in this rapid event but lately
at pretty much every tournament Allen
played was you know he really really had
he was placed well in the final
standings and you know he really did
well in every tournament and you know a
lot of people missed him in the 2018
candidates tournament but yeah we'll see
how it goes I do hope you enjoyed this
game and once again special crazy
congratulations to anyone who who saw
white knight to h5 was winning so as
usual you can check two of my previous
video so you're thinking for watching
and I will see you soon probably with
one more game from round 6 of this nice
rapid tournament end and we're gonna
check out the standings after round six
so thank you all and I'll see you soon